[Music]
[Music]
you've got day participant who's like
six three or something and Chris Pratt
who's the same sort of height these two
big guys and you're standing next to
this little ten inch tall character and
that becomes photographically certainly
a challenge we would always have a
standing 10-inch maquette that we would
put down in the scene and say this is
how he is that gave me and the cast and
everyone else involved a much greater
sense that there was this little
character there on set all the time ah
man what did he do to you there is
something about him that works in a way
where your heart just melts but he's
also a bit of a jerk that selfish jerky
attitude is what makes him work he is
unbelievably adorable at times but if he
just was unbelievably adorable all the
time it would just get so saccharine we
couldn't handle it because he also does
kill people they was sad and three two
one go
[Music]
[Music]
Baby Ruth might be the star of the
entire show we're gonna need to have a
real discussion about your language
legacy effects created the original
sculpt based on artwork created by the
Marvel visual development team and once
legacy had created this practical sculpt
that everyone bought off on we then
handed that over to our visual effects
company and said okay start building
this let's see how he moves and how the
internal vines move and how much do you
make his face move the older Groot has a
Krusty series of panels of wood that you
can use to articulate a room but we've
now are you smooth barked face so how do
you make a smooth bark face move and
animate so it doesn't look like a big
stretchy piece of rubber baby Groot is
much angrier than a dog group and is
hitting Drax every chance he can get
what he hates Drax which is what makes
the moment at the end so sweet when Drax
is the one he really wants to go to just
do you think
[Music]
you are a garden of the galaxy
guardians of the galaxy nope why would
we be the guardians of the galaxy the
Ravagers the sovereign
they want to take over the galaxy so
we're saving the galaxy again I guess
[Music]
I see it within you fear betrayal or any
of you do is yell at each other
stupid raccoons star much you're right
we're family Showtime a-holes
[Music]
[Applause]
it's beautiful
hey what about this little plant can I
smash it with a rock no it's too
adorable to care
[Applause]
[Music]